yeah  and there is  like i'm i'm having fun with this and  and and so is uh  uh peter but  there is that really  like people in chat seem to be very  excited by the possibility that sam's  opponent is cheating he is not cheating  he is like you get games like this in  olympiads you get players who  uh just  play  at the absolute top of their skill  against you for  like you feel kind of weird when this  happens to you when somebody who is so  clearly  uh  below you let's say in rating he just  plays a very very good game of chess  against you but this doesn't look to me  like he's cheating yeah no not at all  you know i i also wanted to mention this  that  if this game would be played online  people would be screaming that ah this  this game was  definitely probably there is something  involved but over the board in the  olympics you know exactly that  everything is  clear and everything is under control